[Music]
don't forget to enter our December
giveaway subscribe comment and leave a
like hey guys as you can tell by the
title itself in this video I'm bringing
the seemingly legit licked outline for
the final season on gaming terms this
outline was sent to me a little bit over
a year ago by person who claims to be
friends with people working on gaming on
special effects Department
you must be muttering why did I not
share it earlier why now there are a few
reasons I did not share this video
earlier first being the fact that I did
not even read it up until a few months
ago and when I finally read it in
October of this year I thought to myself
that it definitely does sound
interesting and something I could see
happening in the final episodes of game
shows but then I also thought to myself
is there any evidence whatsoever
supporting this league because if there
is not then I could not share it with my
viewers and waste their time on yet
another alleged leaked outliner is
probably fake especially so when some of
the main points of the sunna include
events there without any supporting
evidence kind of hard to present this
possible real outline on the final
season of Game of Thrones some of the
main points include the night Kings
conquest reaching all the way south to
the Trident and never being defeated
Howland Reed reappearing and telling
Johnston the truth behind his parentage
Tyrion being executed because he
betrayed Dani and burned down King's
Landing seemingly destroyed Dorne story
coming back into play with a new
character new vol and much more back
then there was little to zero evidence
supporting this alleged outline of the
final season but then in span of only a
few months starting from October this
year to this very day much having a
surface supporting this particular
outline with backing of many credible
League sources as well as with backing
of some official teases and leaks I
finally decided to share this outline
with you as now there's a chance of it
being legit before I get right into it
let me just highlight that it's not only
overall season 8 leaked outline there
are seeds from its source I actually
received leaked outlines for every
single episode of the final season so if
you want me to share it all please let
me know ok let's take a look at what the
season 8 overall outline says he claims
that season 8 starts I'm interfering
with the arrival of John Denny in there
cruisin armies the night king kills
Karstarks and Amber's first jamie rellis
the river lands in the rise of intervals
soon after many reunions ghost appears
in a few scenes and fights alongside Jon
Snow later the mirror reappears - with
her packable sim battle from interval
generosities armed flee the capital with
the golden company 20,000 infantry and
cavalry accompanied by the war elephants
led by new character your insertion the
leader of the golden company a character
named Harry discuss the war plans and
strategy here
frequences - sir say something along the
line I proposed to take storms and first
an I'm pregnant stronghold once they can
it'll give us a secure fastness to which
we may retreat that need and winning it
will prove our strength the golden
company takes from Zendesk base of
operation brain has a vision of the Mad
King burning his grandfather and killing
his uncle then is pregnant she orders in
Sandia mr. Vulcan to stay quiet about
her pregnancy for now since the Stark is
not happy with Danny there's a lot of
drama in Winterfell Ari understands the
situation John and Dana in the crypt
scene John has learned about usual
lineage they discuss nez death the scene
ends with a horn being blown Dean writes
a letter and sends it to King's Landing
Cersei gets a letter we learn Tyrion
betrayed Danny long time ago later
there's a scene explaining it all rains
vision it's about what Tyrion told
Cersei off-camera during their meeting
the single something along the line tell
me Tyrion what do you really want Cersei
is Tyrion do you responded with our
father once told me a good man does
everything in his power to better his
family's position regardless of his own
selfish desires I believe I'm a good man
I want her family to rule Westeros with
me being its king until your child comes
of age
why Cersei as tyrion tyrion replies way
to defend the Lannisters to defend my
blood I might be the lowest of the
Lannisters but I'm still one of us
Cersei responds to that with and you
expect me to March my army snort I have
to disappoint a little brother for death
will never happen
Tyrion answers wait on the contrary you
and I share the same thoughts if John
and Danny are not strong enough to deal
with the debt our forces will not make a
change what we could do is build our
armies for their sacrificing theirs
Cersei says you're in sailing Eastern
fleet vessels we have the backing of the
iron bank their gold borders the largest
sell sort company in this world the
golden company Tyrion says the debt good
once the threat beyond the wall is dealt
with House Lannister will be the only
house strong enough to hold the unknown
Cersei nuts
Taran continues with after the great war
is over and it will be over and when
they come south for you and they will be
ready John and Danny will march to their
death for we will be far superior sturdy
smiliness what about Jaime there on
response I love her brother but Jamie's
an idiot
father knew it you know it I know it
Jaime will not see this as an
opportunity for a family to build a
legacy that will last for a thousand
years when Jamie finds out that you do
not intend to March your armies north he
will abandon you
and he'll March to Winterfell by himself
you will let him go Cersei has a
miscarriage
theme saves your urine kills him huge
revelation of the season is the
ginjuries illegitimate Baratheon he's
not a bastard son of Robert Baratheon
his matter it's Cersei Lannister
Melisandre appears in a true form at
Winterfell she's later burned alive
missin a turns out to be just an assumed
identity of one of faceless men who
Bravo's as it turns out every great
house in Westeros has a faceless man
advising its Lord let's have the
faceless men run this world
sandé is not executed she continues to
serve Danny wait Walker's attack and
conquer Winterfell
many characters die including all the
durables most of the living garments are
gone
the night King nor Viserion are seen in
this battle Danny inner dragons are not
fighting in battle for Winterfell either
they're fighting summer in the South
he's formed a new larger army the night
King raised the new army of the dead
across Westeros by reanimating every
soldier that his diet rather recent wars
John and Danny right dragon and regal
South and have a meeting with sir saying
King's Landing Cersei is given last
chance
brennon same proclaim John the prince
that was promised it later turns out
he's not neither is Danny although
they're both part of the prophecy and so
is the night king there are three heads
of the Dragon the gun company breaks the
contract for the first time abandon
Cersei surcease paranoia cruelty grows
out of control everyone is renomii
Cersei has all realized skilled
she is dubbed the met Queen in his
laning urine is skilled in the red keep
urine wounded Cersei to fulfill her
promise him becoming her husband and
king yearn wanted a wedding you know
says that he fulfill is part of
destroying her enemies it's time for her
to fulfill her part
Cersei refuses thanks yearn for all the
support he provided them breaks their
allegiance Cersei reveals - you're under
the gun and company had broken a
contract no longer fighting for her nor
him serves a state that as of now her
only Ally is vampire Cersei has urine
killed by wildfire
Cersei becomes aroused after burning
urine to death Varys is burned alive
Jaime kill Cersei but it's actually Aria
wearing James face Jamie died protecting
bran Stark the night king conquers
everything north of the Trident the
White Walkers symbols help brain stop
the night King but he's never defeated
all dragons died visitor and killed
Rhaegar and Rogin brain worked into his
area and killed him the night King
survived the living make a pact with the
night king no one means brain does not
manage to learn what the night Kings
motivations are brain only managed to
stop him from conquering the gods eye
and land south of it
Tirion burns down King's Landing
including the Red Keep and the aren't
mountain during his later put under a
trial and executed for religious reasons
and crimes when asked how he did it he
says something along the line to destroy
the wheel Dorne is led by a new
character who is not a Martell Howland
Reed reappears in the final episode and
confirms to John his show parentage
Rhaegar appears in episode 6 he's no
Rhaegar anymore he is no one no
character in-game Eternals no it it's
reeled only to us the viewers then he
gives birth to a daughter
there is no Iron Throne there's no ruler
of the seven kingdoms each of the Seven
Kingdoms has its own roller the new wall
dividing the lengths of the dead and the
lengths of the living agreed upon a pact
between the living and the dead the Jura
moment is named one thousand flowed
Commander of the Nights Watch the night
King rules his new kingdom from interval
the only main characters that will
survive the games are the knight King
ser Davos Seaworth all the Starks Ansari
and bran Stark similarly with his family
Gilly and little Sam Brienne of Tarth
Robin Arryn Yorick reborn Holland Reed
jeremy sandy Jon Snow and Danny finally
personal sorrow that he or she could try
and get short outlined for every single
episode which he or she actually did
then send it to me two months that are
sending this message I'm not sure if I
could share it since I don't know if you
guys want me to cover it in my next
video but if you do make sure to let me
know in the comment section down below
or by liking this video of course this
leaked outline could be yet another fact
outline of the final season but me
personally it seems the most believable
outline I've read as far why
because many O main points of this
alleged leaked outline of the final
seasons seem to go hand in hand with not
only on the leaked photos and leaks
regarding the final season but also the
official tease of season 8 that seems to
support the idea of the nat king
conquering half of Westeros everything
north of the Trident as well as the idea
of a new wall all the ideas that are
some of the main points in this outline
other points such as the opening scene
being a mere affair with John and Dana's
rival all the Iranian sense a not being
happy with any big battle for Winterfell
and the character we do not expect being
in a gamma trance finale are all the
points that have been confirmed to take
place in the final season by official
teases from Entertainment Weekly who
resurrected in season eight set and
shared all this information then we also
have some points such as winter of
falling Devil's reappearing then his arm
is destroyed and seen between John and
Dan in the crypts ending with the horn
being blown all the points that have
been confirmed by leaked photos and
other leaks finally in this outline we
also have points like Tyrion between
Dany
burning
King's Landing and being judged and
executed for all of that as well as new
characters appearing such as the orange
guy and we also have Howland Reed
reappearing all the points that have
been linked a few months ago by the most
credible leaked source all of this
combined makes me think that this
outline might be an actual outline of
the final season because it covers Soul
disconfirm major events and yet it was
sent to me far earlier than any of these
leaks and teases surfaced as I've
already said it had outlines for every
single episode the final season had been
sent to me and if you want me to I'll
share it all in the following days and
as always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]